Київ увійшов у топ п'ятнадцять міст
з найінтенсивнішим автомобільним рухом у світі.
Міжнародна аналітична компанія "TomTom" проаналізувала
трафік чотирьохсот мегаполісів  у 2018 році і з'ясувала:
столичні водії лише у ранковому трафіку щоденно втрачають майже півгодини.
Переконатися у цьому легко, провівши хоча б один день на київських дорогах.
Однак у чому причина рекордних корків і які шанси на успіх у боротьбі з ними?
Дев’ята ранку. Автомобільна дорога, відома водіям як  Житомирська траса,
одна з найзавантаженіших артерій міста.
Нею щоденно в’їжджають до столиці
та проходять транзитом тисячі автомобілів.
Віднедавна Київська міська адміністрація обмежила рух вантажівок тут
у вечірні та ранкові години пік.
Це зробили для того, щоб розвантажити столичний трафік.
Водії великогабаритного транспорту чекають на узбіччі,
допоки їм дозволять рушити о десятій.
Мені не подобається, у мене немає часу, той самий затор буде на Кільцевій, от і все.
Куди він подінеться? А якби вони поступово проходили,
то не було б цього затору.  Година пік – це зрозуміло.
Але хто хоче і так його перечекає.
Раніше обмеження для вантажівок вводили
тільки за спекотної погоди або в хуртовини.
Вже два тижні поліція і "Муніципальна варта" чергують на автостраді щодня.
У перші дні контролю на узбіччях стояло до 500 вантажівок,
нині їх зо два десятки. Тепер аналогічні обмеження починають діяти
і на великих автошляхах, що ведуть до столиці з інших напрямків.
Окрім безпосередньо заборони на в’їзд в місто,
іде ж певна роз’яснювальна робота з перевізниками,
з логістичними компаніями, з крупними торговими мережами
з приводу того, аби вони правильно й ефективно планували свій шлях і час
відповідно своїх доставок, аби просто не створювати незручності киянам.
Одинадцята нуль нуль. Прилеглі до Житомирської автостради вулиці
навіть після того, як у транспортний потік вливаються вантажівки,
все ще рухаються у нормальному режимі.
Однак так триває недовго. Ми приєднуємося до киянина Олександра,
який їде у справах до центру міста.
Затори поступово беруть в лещата його і сотні інших автомобілів.
Попереду - будівництво Шулявського мосту.
Це, скажімо, неправильний системний підхід до такої проблеми
тому що одночасно в один період часу
кілька дуже важливих артерій вони перерізані.
Шулявський міст довгий час був у аварійному стані.
Його повністю закрили на демонтаж у березні.
Відтоді водії, які оминути це будівництво не можуть,
стоять тут у заторах регулярно.
Олександр такі ситуації використовує з користю:
слухає цікаві інтерв'ю, подкасти, вдосконалює англійську.
Але зізнається, трафік суттєво впливає на ритм його життя і продуктивність.
Зокрема через трафік я перебудував свою роботу так
тепер у мене субота-неділя є робочими
і воно набагато цікавіше, насиченіше виходить.
Звичайно, деякі партнери спочатку кривили носи,
але потім зрозуміли, що ефективність від цього тільки зростає.
Тринадцята година. Центральна частина Києва щільно запаркована.
Водії йдуть у справах, лишаючи свої автівки на тротуарах, зупинках,
смугах громадського транспорту.
Раніше з цим боролися хіба що штрафами.
Тепер у середмісті щоденно працює 15 евакуаторів.
Це ще одна нова ініціатива київської міської влади у боротьбі з заторами.
Експерт Дмитро Беспалов порахував: економічні збитки від київських заторів
становлять до 3 мільйонів доларів щоденно.
Київ не розвиває громадський транспорт,
Київ робить упор на метрополітен як основний вид транспорту,
а той досяг межі пропускної здатності.
Наземний транспорт, на жаль, не розвивається,
ми з колегами робили прогноз по рівню автомобілізації та по кількості автомобілів у місті
на 1000 мешканців. Там просто шалений тренд росту.
Ми думаємо, що це внаслідок деградації громадського транспорту
і внаслідок доступних автомобілів з Європи.
Подібні проблеми характерні не тільки для столиці,
але й для решти українських міст-мільйонників.
І хоча офіційно жодних замірів інтенсивності міського руху в Києві
наразі не проводиться, про надмірну кількість авто свідчить
ще й стан інфраструктурних об’єктів Києва, наприклад мостів.
Більшість з них побудовані 30-50 років тому
і не розраховані на нинішній трафік.
До прикладу, Південним мостом зараз рухається
до 100 тисяч тон транспорту щоденно,
а розрахований він на 20, тому руйнується на очах.
Наступні 10 років ми будемо витрачати на те,
щоб не побудувати  нові мости, розв'язки, тунелі чи дороги,
а просто щоб полагодити ті інфраструктурні об'єкти, які у нас є зараз
нам треба пріорітезовувати громадський і спільний транспорт.
Тобто більше людей в машині, це треба заохочувати, таксі, каршерінг,
розбудовувати велосипедну інфраструктуру.
Покращення міського руху – одне із завдань Максима Бахматова,
який віднедавна працює радником київського мера Віталія Кличка.
Він почав свою роботу з того, що об’єднав представників профільних департаментів
столичної адміністрації, активістів, велосипедистів, експертів, поліцію в Kyiv Traffic Group.
Учасники групи зустрічаються щотижня.
Наша задача – почати вимірювати, почати керувати, почати вичищати,
почати забороняти рух,
щоб кияни могли пересуватися швидше і безпечніше.
Суттєво помітно вже, бо з 20 полос громадського руху
для автобусів, тролейбусів та маршруток
12 вже щоденно контролюються поліцією,
більше 5 мільйонів штрафів вже винесено.
І поки в КМДА підводять підсумки перших трьох тижнів робити Kyiv Traffic Group
і розмірковують, як залучити більше евакуаторів
і зробити безпечним рух біля шкіл та дитячих садків,
наступає вечірня година пік.
Їдучи в міському автобусі,
пасажири діляться своїми рецептами покращення руху.
Було би класно, якби всюди по Києву було метро та інші види рейкового транспорту
такі як трамваї, можливо монофунікулери,
як це є в Європі та в інших країнах.
Вечірній Київ живе не менш бурхливим життям, ніж вранішній.
Міським автобусом дістаємося до зупинки на Хрещатику,
неподалік від якої в обід працювали евакуатори.
На місці оштрафованих автомобілів, порушуючи правила дорожнього руху,
стали десятки нових.
За кілька годин на зміну вечірнім заторам прийдуть декілька годин нічної тиші.
А вже зранку Київ знову почне їхати, стояти в заторах
і пробувати змінитися на краще.